So traveling, traveling is basically the concept
of either moving from server to server
or connecting to a server in the first place,
or indeed our server moving to a new map.
So two notions that are instantly worth kind of highlighting
is the idea of seamless and non seamless travel.
These are kind of slightly more meaningful
from the client's perspective.
Seamless travel means that there will be a non-blocking,
i.e. asynchronous operation when traveling to the new server.
On the other hand, in contrast, non seamless travel
is gonna cause a blocking load.
So this is a little bit like when you load a texture
or a sound, if you do a synchronous or a blocking load,
it's basically going to,
a blocking call is gonna force,
disconnect the client from the server.
And then once that's done,
it will reconnect the client to the same server,
which will now have the new map loaded.
So there are three scenarios in which non seamless,
i.e. the kind of blocking load
where they disconnect and reconnect must occur.
When loading a map for the first time,
either we don't have this map kind of cached,
when connecting to a new server for the first time,
and when ending a multiplayer game and starting a new one.
And then there are kind of three core functions
that drive and utilize these different forms of travel.
So we'll kind of quickly look at those.
So first we have the browse function.
Essentially, this is a hard reset when loading a new map,
and it will always result in non seamless travel,
as we kind of said about the disconnecting, reconnecting.
This causes the server to disconnect all current clients
before traveling to the new map.
And the dedicated servers can't travel to other servers.
So when we're talking about traveling,
we can travel via a URL.
That URL can either be a server IP,
or it can be a kind of a local map content location.
This has to be a map location, a server.
In the context of server,
it cannot travel to another server
because servers can't connect to servers.
So it has to be a local map URL.
And then we have server travel and client travel.
So server travel is held in UWorld,
client travel is held inside the player controller,
and this kind of occurs in order.
So server travel is for the server only,
and it will jump the server to a new level.
All connected clients are gonna follow that server,
and the server is in charge of calling that function.
And it's the server itself that will then call
client travel to the connected clients,
to each of the clients that are connected.
So at that point, client travel would get called,
and well, okay, the server can call client travel.
If client travel is called from a client,
then it's about traveling to a new server.
If client is called from the server,
then it's generally gonna be an instruction
to transition to a new map.
And this is gonna be that seamless travel
where we're going to maintain that connection to the server
and just move to a new map.
But obviously we already talked about the various situations
where this is impossible,
i.e. we don't have this map loaded before,
we've never connected to the server before,
or we're ending a multiplayer game.
So the other kind of thing that's worth mentioning
when we're talking about traveling
or transitioning between servers, or more importantly, maps,
it's worth bearing in mind that the game mode
is one of these things that will persist by default,
but also the game mode has this function,
getSeamlessLevel, a travel actors list,
that basically gives you the ability to specify
a list of actors that will travel
between levels seamlessly.
So anything that you need to kind of persist
to kind of keep your game up and running,
the things that you only expected to get spawned once,
that might be things that you put
in this SeamlessTravel actor list.
All player control, all controllers for players
with valid player states as part of the,
players from the server's perspective will persist.
All player controllers from the server's perspective
will persist.
And all local player controllers,
so if you're the connected client,
your player controller will persist between travel.